París Roma Berlín Bangkok Sydney son
algunas ciudades en el mundo que se
sumaron a la hora de la tierra la
dinámica es Apagar las luces por una
hora con el objetivo de hacer conciencia
sobre el cambio climático y el consumo
excesivo de energía que la modernidad
requiere monumentos icónicos de la
humanidad se oscurecieron por 60 minutos
pero también se hace un llamado a que la
gente común se sume a la iniciativa
pedirle a la gente que apague las luces
por una hora Es verdaderamente una
acción simbólica muy importante inspira
a la gente a reflexionar sobre su estilo
de vida y en Cómo pueden hacer una gran
diferencia para proteger el medio
ambiente
la hora de la tierra nació en 2007 un
movimiento impulsado por el fondo
mundial para la naturaleza
wwwf por sus siglas en inglés inició en
sidney y ahora el año con mayor
participación el movimiento se ha
extendido a 185 países distintos
movimientos simbólico pero que busca
influir en las decisiones políticas para
luchar contra el cambio climático
la ruptura del equilibrio del planeta
puede resolverse de dos maneras mediante
acciones individuales y mediante
decisiones colectivas sin duda lo que
falta hoy es un paso adelante de la
política y sus instituciones para dar
luz verde a un cambio real No cabe duda
sin embargo que las elecciones
individuales tienen un enorme impacto
a la colectividad
el cambio climático es posiblemente la
batalla más grande que tiene la
generación actual enfrente Naciones
Unidas recientemente ha marcado 2035
como el año límite para evitar el punto
de no retorno climático acciones como la
hora de la tierra Aunque controvertidas
entre los más críticos son un símbolo de
conciencia ambiental global